hello my name is kendall amke and i
chair the department of agronomy at iowa
state university
it's a pleasure to be here today to talk
about 40 years of plant breeding
first our order i owe a thank you to all
those involved with me being the 2020
recipient of the national association of
plant breeders
public sector plant breeding impact
award
truly an honor to receive this award and
i want to thank jin ming yu for
nominating me of course the folks who
wrote the reference letters and um as
well as the awards committee at napb
uh this award that i did not expect to
receive and and getting an award like
this from your peers really is an honor
i do appreciate it
i also want to thank all the plant
breeders at iowa state university uh
here's a list of them on this slide here
fortunately like someone like bill bevis
have retired recently and i've had a
chance over the last 15 years as
department chair to hire a lot of these
plant breeders so even though i haven't
been active in plant breed i have an
impact in other ways for example i've
heard bill beavis i've hired danny sing
already sing walter souza jin ming yu
thomas lubersted and maybe a couple of
others of cb muhammad maybe a couple of
others who aren't on this slide
anymore so it's a pleasure to have them
in our program i am still a strong
supporter of cultivar development
programs we have three right now at iowa
state maria solis's program in biomass
sorghum danny singh's program is soybean
artising's program in mungbean and herb
bean and you could say thomas
liverstadt's program in developing
double half plate inducers as well
i want to talk about my graduate student
years because i think it's informative
and and i think shaped who i eventually
be came not completely
but but had a big impact on me certainly
as a graduate student mentor i was a
reluctant undergraduate i wanted to stay
home and farm that wasn't possible
in 1976 so i ended up going to
university of illinois and i majored in
i started out as a major in ag
engineering for almost two years
i discovered agronomy that looked like
something that was closer to what i
wanted to do because my big goal in life
was to impact farmers
if i couldn't farm that i want to be in
a position to impact farming and at
first ag engineering looked like a way
to do that it probably was and but plant
breeding also looked like a good way to
do that as well so i went changed my
major to agronomy went over
and got an advisor my advisor had to be
an alfalfa breeder darrell miller
daryl miller introduced me to john
dudley john dudley hired me as an
undergrad and kind of the rest is
history so john dudley became my took
the risk of taking me as a master's
student in his program in 1980
um john gotti's ms and pbs that purdue
in his ms and phd at iowa state
university in 1955 and 1956 and plant
breeding was cp wilsey
he was trained as a
as an alfalfa breeder and that
information will be irrelevant a little
later here's a picture of of john with
some of these and some of his students
including me in 2002 at the long term
selection conference i just want to show
a fun picture it's kind of nice to see
who some of john's students were the
gentleman standing right to john's
rights john miles and john miles had a
big impact on me because i worked for
john as an undergraduate as he was
getting his phd with john and john is a
rocky area breeder on down at seven i i
believe he's retired now
and you may know some of the other
people in this picture as well
through my master's thesis i had time to
rethink and study i really did
appreciate that um i became a graduate
student i wasn't sure what to do john
told me i should read i asked him what
to read he told me and i went and read
it and
so i had a lot of time to do a lot of
reading i left my master's program
believing i was pretty well read of
course it wasn't as well read as i
thought it was but but i was pretty well
read
um john was a great teaching role model
he's a voracious reader and these are
all characteristics that you know is
trying to emulate he's an excellent
writer excellent editor he's a patient
human being i think all plant breeders
are patient and i learned a lot from him
from auto touch about auto tetraploid
genetics
and
in fact i worked on auto tetraploid
genetics for my master's thesis mass
selection and brain depression and
throughout the tetrapoint may synthetic
so so we had a lot of fun i had a lot of
fun at university of illinois as a place
to be at the time
i ended up leaving illinois to go to the
university of iowa state university to
get my phd degree i had my choice of
working with either this man arnold hall
hour or bill russell either of them
would have been excellent choices i
ended up working with dr hallar because
of my interest in quantitative genetics
that i developed from working with dr
dudley
arnold also got his bs
his ms and phd degrees at iowa state
university in 1958 with george sprague
in 1960 uh with bill russell because
george sprague had left in 58 to
pick up to move to with the usda to uh
dc
to head up the corn serial
investigations unit what's now the usda
um so you can see now that john and
arnold were both
contemporaries but they didn't overlap
at iowa state
but they have iowa state as a connection
and here's a picture uh circa 1985 from
our project at iowa state university
um
with dr hall r there in the center of
the picture
let's meet
um on the left side of the picture of
course in the leather vest right behind
arnold's linda pollock who was with the
ars she had just recently been hired
into the usda program at the time
um and is now retired
my phd program was a lot different than
my master's program we worked like dogs
we must have planned to have been
planting in
early 1982 through about 1985 probably
20 to
30 acres
of plots and nursery a year and hand
harvesting it it was a lot of work
so i didn't have the time to think and
read at least during the daytime hours
so you had to take what time there was
to rethink a study i'm not saying it
wasn't fun because it was
uh it was just a different kind of fun
and you had to spend your time a lot
different arnold like dr dudley was also
a voracious reader he still is i'm sure
they both are
uh he was an excellent writer he was an
excellent editor and he was also a
patient human being and i learned a lot
from him as well
and there's a lot of overlapping
overlapping interests both of these
gentlemen would turn something you give
them the read around in the evening
almost always that was that's probably
considered miraculous this day and age
but uh but they were both able to do it
and did do it so these two gentlemen
both studlian
hall hour were connected by george
sprigg george sprague was also at the
university of illinois while i was there
after he retired that's where he spent
his retirement years and i don't think
he ever really did slow down i consider
this kind of an iconic photo
george sprague there in the middle of
the back with the arrow over him to his
to his right is earl patterson and to
his left is john dudley on the front
from left to right's bob lambert art
hooker of plant pathologist denton
alexander
and of course john lonnin who
was the one that developed illinois
super sweet sweet corn he was a
geneticist in the biology department
and george was the foundation of the
well he wasn't really the person who
started the iowa state maze program um
the iowa state mesa program was started
by merle jenkins sprague replaced
jenkins when
jenkins moved to dc
but sprague was the person who i think
ties all these people together including
john
and
and arnold and me and had a lot of
influence i think in how all of us
thought about maze breeding at the time
i considered george sprague to be one of
the best writers and thinkers ever in
may's breeding
i have the honor i believe of being
maybe the only person i don't think i
don't know anybody else
who's who has the pictures of their both
of their major advisors on shot glasses
um both of these are from international
symposia plant breeding symposiums held
in mexico city these are tequila shot
glasses so i thought let's show that in
i was able to find them
and
so i thought that was a nice little
tidbit to add to the talk today another
thing that connects them i want to point
out another gentleman who's been
influential in my career charlie singh
who also is connected through iowa state
university charlie's a
from illinois originally got his bs
degree in agronomy my department at iowa
state university in 1960 his master's in
wheat breeding with elmer heine at
k-state his
phd in genetic statistics with bob maul
at north carolina state charlie went on
to become the first one the first human
geneticist hired in the human genetics
department at the university of michigan
he worked primarily on the quantitative
genetics of coronary heart disease and
hypertension there i met charlie at a
field day
probably 25 years ago a popcorn field
day in ames here
charlie has got royalties from popcorn
and red lines which is something i can't
claim to have been able to do
uh but and so charlie's been a very
influential person in my career
he started his career
well his phd was on inverting depression
this paper here singh maul and hanson
warren hanson uh in bringing up in two
populations of maize and then i think
probably one of the best studies i did
during my career was quantitation next
in brilliant synthetic maize population
of jody edwards and which is kind of a
follow up for that study and actually a
follow-up to some work that both arnold
and john dudley had done as well
uh charlie the influence that charlie's
had on me came through some meetings
that he held over the course of 20 25
years every other years in montana at a
guest ranch it was kind of based around
wendell berry on the left wendell was at
every one of those meetings as was wes
jackson he was sort of the basis for
this meeting but as a place for people
in human genetics and agriculture came
together at charlie's invitation to
discuss
philosophy if you will in both
agriculture medicine and research i
learned a lot at those meetings i still
talk to charlie every week in fact i'm
gonna go see him
in person next week so big influence on
how i think about stuff is important
person finally i need to thank my
graduate students i wouldn't have done
anything without them
i'm very proud of all my graduate
students they've gone all going on to do
good things during their careers and
quite a few of them now work in industry
some place out there in the world
i want to take some time to talk about
some of my corn breeding career
things have changed a lot since i
started in plant breeding i'm not going
to talk about that much but what we did
we worked primarily on five things
population improvements selection
response epistasis inbreeding inbring
depression and heterosis
um and
i think we did some pretty important
work in all of those areas and we'll
highlight some of that now
we did a lot of work with iowa stiff
stock synthetic bss as we sometimes call
16 line synthetic that george sprague
started putting together when he's at
missouri before moving to ames in the
30s
population is still around we're still
doing selection in it it was just unique
it's a unique population there's no
other way of saying it it's a source of
several important inbreds
didn't respond inbred progeny selection
even though everybody thought it should
certainly steve everhart thought it
should have
responded very well to reciprocal
recurrence selection
has equal additive and dominance
variances every bearing study has ever
done shown that
uh contrary to sales and pollinated
varieties almost every other synthetic
the additive variance is easily two
times or more the dominus variance added
variance didn't decrease with selection
in this population
reciprocal recurrent selection did
decrease thomas variance significantly
though
and had a unique variance component
structure as jody found out in his phd
dissertation
and this is one of the papers out of
jody's phd dissertation i i'm going to
use it just because i think it's
probably one of the best experiments
that i was ever been involved with
design and execution-wise jody ran it
came out so well because he ran
simulation models on genetic design
experiment he extended and applied new
theory around inbreeding we grew 200
lines in each of five generations
thousand entry study two reps six
locations total environments twelve
thousand plots it was a beast
and we used a novel experimental design
that worked out really well that jody
and i had come up to conduct this
experiment in
what did i learn from that study the
modeling theory paid off it was worth
the time and effort having good
questions i think is always important
and understanding the precision with
which we could estimate some of the
parameters we were interested in was
quite important to us too i learned i
was wrong about a lot too what i thought
i knew about inbreeding and inbreeding
depression
i was interested in the variance of f
and also into the variance of the rate
of inbreeding depression the rate of in
britain should say depression my
apologies is confounded with the so
individual breeding value jody was able
to demonstrate to me i did not know that
basically that meant that individuals
with large breeding values are going to
inbreed more than individuals with small
breeding values of course larger
breeding values for things like yield or
what plant breeders want we learned that
stiff stock had a negative covariance
structure between breeding values and
dominance deviations of inbred
individuals call this d1 and this led to
lower
guarantee breeding values and hence
reduced response to inbred prodigy
selection we were able to explain some
things we didn't understand
and we had a lot of fun
the other nice piece of work jody and i
did which i won't go through in detail
is the paper of just which was not part
of his phd dissertation that we wrote
for the heterosis conference it was also
held in mexico city
in 1988 i believe the paper was
published in 89 where we laid out a new
framework for looking at heterosis that
was based on some
previous work that had been done where
we were trying to separate panmectic
heterosis from the recovery from
heterosis that results from the recovery
of inbreeding depression there's a lot
of reasons i was interested in that and
which i will write about after i stepped
down as chair in three or four years
because i think that there's still some
misunderstandings about this but this
has been an interesting paper for us the
question is is did it all matter
i think it did
we were able to add we had questions you
know we were curious uh we were able to
answer some of those questions and learn
about things
uh we and we were i was able to train a
lot of really good graduate students i
think in the end it's all about people
uh as well
and and i was i'm very proud of the
graduate students post docs and visiting
scientists who i didn't list that worked
with over the years and and what they're
doing and the the influence we may have
had on on those people while they were
here
you look at my most cited papers you
know is is that a measure of impact i
don't think so though the heterosis one
does come up on the list which makes um
makes me happy the the 2002 paper jody
did not make that list most of the stuff
that's highlighted that i have that was
cited a little bit was was old rflp and
ssr work that we were doing
with mike lee at the time
almost everything that we did i did
during my career was was based on the
bottom four parts of this pyramid
germplasm breeding methodology data
collection and data management
i put this slide together to show that
almost everything has come after that is
built on this foundation
and
of course by the time i became
department chair 15 years ago
i was you know these newer things were
starting to really come online
and i haven't done as much work in that
arena but but without these bottom four
things none of the stuff that
especially large maze breeding programs
are doing now particularly would be able
to do i just wanted to kind of make that
while i'm here
i want to
end
with
this coda
from um
a paper by ernest mayer and pnas called
the objects of selection
and so ernst wrote he wrote a whole
paper on selection of what the unit of
selection was he goes when rereading my
analysis i was quite surprised how
rarely i had to refer to the genetic
aspects responsible for the phenotype
apparently it does not matter very much
how the genes are combined or how much
the genotype has to be modified provided
the resulting phenotype is favored by
selection what counts is the
adaptiveness of the end product
he goes on to point out that he's
indebted to richard lewinton who just
passed away this past
fourth of july weekend and livington was
certainly one of my favorite writings on
a whole bunch of things i didn't always
agree with him but i always liked to
read him
so with that i'd like to thank you and i
think there's maybe some time for
questions